welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar Studies on
malignancies with a novel proliferation
biomarker it is presented by Martin Shaw
the business development manager at RO
cell my name is Judy O'Rourke and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots labret is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming Martin Shaw I will
now turn the presentation over to him ok
thank you for joining me ladies and
gentlemen good morning or afternoon
depending where you're on the world I'm
going to make a presentation on a novel
proliferation biomarker and issues in
malignancies in particular I'm going to
concentrate on the proliferation
biomarker thymidine kinase one it's
quite a long presentation so I'm going
to break it up into sections
approximately has shown here first a bit
about in general Agilent biomarkers then
thymidine kinase is a tumor biomarker
it's rolling into mushroom malignancies
in solid tumors in drug discovery a bit
on the assay and then a summary
discussion if some long presentations
I'll be repeating parts of it to make it
easier to follow I hope and also for
those that really interested in certain
sections of it
so was issue of a biomarker is any
substance is associated with the
presence of the tumor there's only three
source I'm going to talk about now
basically genetic cell surface markers
serum protein markers and then
proliferation biomarkers I know they're
either biomarkers such as multiple long
links but I'm not going to discuss them
today talking about genetic or
immunological biomarkers and there's a
lot of these here to pee do one they are
seven and others they aid in the choice
of therapy but they do not indicate
therapy success and they're not
indicates a tumor growth
there's also serum protein biomarkers
and these mostly indicate UMMS and as
many of these again see a PSA and many
more but there are very few serum
biomarkers of cell proliferation a venue
serum by market lattaker particularly
for advanced disease and this has been
stated for two of the most important
cancer types for example for PSA in
prostate cancer excuse me you must be
stressed the PSA level is not an
absolute mark of escape and you can have
clinical progression with normal PSA in
breast cancer it's been stated not one
of the circulating markers are shown
clinical utility to support issues as an
independent predictive biomarkers
predictive is something I'm going to
come back to so our hypothesis is that
most current tumor biomarkers measure
what's happened the past rate of change
such as doubling time the current
situation such as tumor mass or white
blood cell numbers but what really
matters is tumor growth and
proliferation biomarker can help to show
this in a Canadian choice of therapy
resulted if they're low watchful waiting
or less aggressive therapy and if
they're high more aggressive therapy and
they can provide a measures you can the
growth and they can aid in stratifying
patients and subjects and studies and
one reason to only treat those tumors
which are growing is that to be anti
tumour drugs or toxic they have side
effects they're expensive and they drive
therapy resistance so going on to
explain to a bit more a proliferation
biomarkers most of at the moment are
immuno is the logical biomarkers the
gold standard is ki-67 a protein
expressing cells during the growth cycle
PCNA which talk and talk about and then
tk1
or thymidine kinase one which I'm going
to talk about mostly for the rest of
this presentation
vitamin E kinase one is a key enzyme in
DNA production and
Croesus during the S phase when DNA
synthesis occurs so the percentage of
cells staining is the proliferation
index and it provides a measure of the
rate of tumor growth
but these are immunised illogical
procedures they require biopsy they are
invasive the labor-intensive they only
show the space of a small part of one
human if there's metastasis what's going
on there and they're very low
reproducibility because they're
subjective
so there's a need for a biomarker that
indicates the ongoing body activity of
the malignant disease that is applicable
to stand a serum sample and that can be
determined with a routine analytical
method and I'm going to present you that
their serum thymidine kinase one as the
potential to be such a marker a little
bit about what serum saying some
Deaconess is excuse me
serum climbing tiny has been an
established proliferation biomarker
mainly for him logic malignancies for 35
years it's been studied in many types of
solid tumor and when tk1 is using the
little immunological staining it is
highly associated with the gold standard
preparation biomarker ki-67 what does it
do it's coupled phosphate to sign the
deed as a key step in DNA production and
this coupling of phosphate the fireman
forms the basis of the enzymatic
activity assays for thymidine kinase one
as I mentioned in solid tumors is found
in many types probably is expressed in
all of them I'm going to look at the
application of TK 1 I'm going to talk
first about hematological malignancies
and most of increase there was a serum
TK 1 activity I found in most forms of
leukemia and it's been used for a long
time in many ways for example it can be
a discriminator disease stage provide
prognostic information can aid in
monitoring therapy response or relapse
and indeed disease progression look at a
clinical staging this is a study on non
horses do farm and as you can see as the
disease progresses the serum tk1
activity increases
to study on chronic lymphocytic leukemia
and again you can see has the disease
progresses the REI stage increases the
serum level of tk1 increases and
interestingly when an elevated tk1 is
found in subjects have an apparently
indolent disease disease not progressing
they have an increased risk of disease
progression could be used to make
prognosis this is the current
lymphocytic leukemia and you can see in
those which have a low tk1 level less
than seven years later the at least 50%
survival time is about six years but
when they have a high level the physics
and survival is only about a year so
it's a very strong prognostic factor
similarly in non-hodgkins lymphoma in
those have a low level you can see that
50% of those survive around again about
six or seven years or so to have a high
level survive again only about a year
degree me note that the level of T k1 is
different this is because of the
different cell types involved and the
different patient populations to be used
to look at protease progression here's a
study on acute myeloid leukemia and then
top two subjects with your stable course
you can see that TK one level stays low
and in the bottom two which led to death
you can see that prior to death is a
rapid increase in the serum TK 1 levels
it can be used profitably together with
other biomarkers and serum TK 1
activities seem to reflect a combination
of tumor mass and proliferation rate my
good perhaps I was simplifying so it
gives an indication at the number of
cells which are growing
it correlates with the proliferation
index as I mentioned the gold standard
for assessing to agressivity it
correlates with the peripheral blood
lymphocyte count site correlates with
tumor mass so vital not been widely used
well one problem is the acid
intracellular activity k1 is a tensioner
the serum tk1 exist as complexes of
different sizes and enzyme activities
some cereal contain tk1 active
inhibitors and see enzyme activity Isis
may underestimate CMT k1
the gold standard assays fatigue you
want user lights radioactive tracers
commercial assays may utilize
specialized equipment and we're going to
put you later
the Evo SS can solve these problems
so I'm going to first talk very briefly
about the amino acid tyrosine kinase one
particularly the our so tk2 to little
Iser
it's serum tk1 Falls complexes of many
molecular weights and enzyme activities
but they all expressed the tico 210
antigen
and as you can see when you plot the
enzyme activity against the molecular
weight and at the same time do Western
blotting on the different fractions you
can see that where there is enzyme
activity there is the presence of tk1
where and you can see it by looking at
the TK 210 antigen and antigen specific
for the TK 1
the SOT k21 Eliza it uses monoclonal
antibodies against the unique amino acid
sequence the TK 210 antigen and
importantly a unique pre acid treatment
releases TK 1 from the CMT k1 complexes
and exposed to the T go to 298 excites
when you look at the diagnostic power of
the enzyme activity si and TK to turn
Eliza they give very similar data and
this is good because it means that you
can use the Eliza a superior analytical
method to to you sorry and build on the
historic data
we have done some early studies on using
the tek-tips and utilizing hematologic
cancers and you can see that in healthy
subjects it's low in subjects prior to
treatments elevated during treatment is
up and down depending how the state of
patient and then after treatment in
remission it goes down to approximately
normal levels
so talking about tear co2 analyzer in
teams illogical malignancies
it's a biomarker of cell proliferation
serum levels reflect disease activity
tp1 can need inpatient subject
classification can be used tk1 Caviezel
prognosis tk1 can be used on a disease
progression
it adds information studies performing
at the biomarkers and it can be used in
many malignancies it gives a good agree
with clinical results based on tk1
enzyme activity it gives the convenience
of microtiter eliza it's an open system
and it see marked
you
so that's the bit about the almost
historical data on the use of TK want to
study teams or look at you EBIT
illogical illnesses but now with the
improved technology one can use it more
to look at solid tumors as I mentioned
earlier TK 1 is expressed in salaat
immunised illogically in solid tumors
but many have been shown probably all
but it's not been widely studied in
solid tumors
and the reason it goes back to this the
fact that in theorem t k1 is circulate
as complexes with different molecular
weights and different enzyme activities
but they all Express the TK 210 antigen
and more than that many of the TK 1
aggregates in serum with solid human
subjects are enzyme activity
enzymatically inactive but they all
respect to TK 2 to an antigen this can
be shown here in a subject with prostate
cancer the open circle shows the
distribution of enzyme activity in blood
donors the black diamonds show the
distribution in a subject with prostate
cancer and underneath you have the
western blotting for each of these
fragments and I want to draw your
attention to fragment two fractions
fourteen onwards what is a strong
immunological expression of TK one but
no enzyme activity so in subjects with
solid tumors the eliezer acid is more
sensitive because it picks up these TK 1
forms which lack or have love enzyme
activity and as I mentioned that the
Eliza
era so TK to tell you lies as unique
free IC treatment the brakes of the silk
complexes and expose the TK 2 to
nitrogen and here you can see the effect
of this in a subject in subjects with
breast cancer on the the TK 2 T nitrogen
like the TK 210 concentration here under
the curve is not 0.9 but a TK 1 activity
it's not point seven nine so you have a
better diagnostic power but more
importantly if you look at the
sensitivity at a TK tooten concentration
is not 0.5 and for the TK 1 activity is
not point to both cinema specificity so
that it Eliza is about twice as
sensitive for measuring t k1 is subjects
with breast cancer as I
can be combined profitably with other
tumors tumor Marcus here's a study where
they looked at see a 15-3 and breast
cancer and you can see the blue line
which is see a 15-3
and you can see the red line which is
the the TK 2 10 and then it can bind
early get the black line and where you
have even better performance so this is
a good point because when you combine
the mass it's an indication and mass
such as CA 53 with an indication of
proliferation such as TK 1 you get a
better result it has been shown
similarly in prostate cancer you have
compassed with pro CPSA the red line is
the propria say the bluish line is the
TK 210 very similar but if you combine
them you get a bit better result there
so you can say that in diagnosed
subjects with potential prostate cancer
for such as which have found to have
prostate cancer
TK 210 is about as good as the loo
prostate biomarker Pro PSA but combine
the Proby assay is even better
so looking at solid tumors the
conclusions the ISO tk2 till I see text
TK 1 holds missed by enzymatic assays
the TK 2 did life get better
discriminates between healthy control
subjects with solid tumors could be used
to study many types of tumor as
information to studies perform with
other biomarkers and it's cmart
so that's a bit of the use of the TQM
USA and tt1 and activity assays in solid
in lignin C's I'm not going to talk
about it a bit in drug discovery and in
a key step in all drug development is
this evaluation the product in vitro and
the SA of T table under the RS otk to
catalyze kit offers the potential to
study anti proliferation effects in
vitro there are many biomarkers of cell
death in vitro the tk1 sa is an
indication cell growth in Ventura
is like proof of principle here you're
looking at the concentration detected
out for TK 210 compared with the number
cells present and you can see the pretty
good correlation
is a study where a leukemia cell line
has been studied in vitro where the
cells have been exposed to the
anti-cancer drug doxorubicin the blue
line is the intracellular content of TK
232 k1 and the red line is the
concentration of TK 1 in the supernatant
as the level of drug administered
increases the first thing you see is
that the level of TK 1 interestingly
increases this issue to the fact that
dr. rosen attacks DNA and the cell is
trying to grow more DNA so you get an
upregulation to k1 as the cell as the
dose of drug increases the intracellular
concentration ticket one Falls and you
start to see the appearance of TK 1 in
the supernatant as the cells die
and this is very interesting because in
cell culture some in clinical trials
when you use thymidine based scanning
agents to do positively positron
emission you can see at the emission in
the issue initiation a therapy these the
tumors glow you get what's called a
flare which disappears as the the drug
becomes more effective so what you're
seeing in the microtiter plate is
Scimitar can be seen in clinic so
looking at TK one in the microtiter
plate it shows it's a trend potentially
a translational biomarker
we're also seeing now that tk1 seems to
be a very good companion dying
complementary diagnostics to cdk4 six
inhibitors they seem to these prevent
cells entering the s-1 phase and tk1 is
present in the s1 phases so the effect
of cdk for six limiters can potentially
be seen very clearly by measuring
changes in tk1 certainly anti-hormonal
therapy seemed to do the same thing
following studies in microtiter plate
the next episode of the dinner graphs
that is and here's an advantage of
eliezer compared to enzyme activity F is
because Mouse and humid tk1 or
immunologically distinct so you can be
dense potentially get improved
monitoring as in the graphs in mice we
are performing studies on this and if
you've got any studies in this silk we'd
be very pleased to hear from you
so I'm now going to through showing that
tk1 Eliza can be valuable in clinical
studies and in drug discovery I'm now
going a little bit on the SA method and
I'm going to divide this part of just
some small parts the analytical
challenges the assay cell performance
data the handling of tk1 further
information and discussion so as I
mentioned twice already molecular weight
of TKO and complex and specific
activities differ between normal tune
subjects and some tk1 aggregates from
serum social so tunes are enzymatically
inactive okay as you can see in in
mythology subjects where there is pretty
much the expression of DK to turn where
there is enzyme activity and this but
you can see here there is solid tumors
that a lot of the TK one is not
enzymatically active but it still
expresses the TK 210 antigen and so can
be measured by the osot catatonia Lizer
the pretreatment of the samples releases
at TK one tetanus from the line vetted
by complexes and expose the TK to
another epitope so you get greater
sensitive solid tumors and more
consistent results between subjects and
types of malignancy described in the kid
very quickly
it's a microtiter plate sandwich Eliza
it uses monoclonal antibodies against
the epitope TK 2 T and most importantly
a unique create a treatment releases TK
1 from the serum complexes and exposes
the antigen site
the method is very simple as I mentioned
the pretreatment of the sample you add
it to microtiter plate code to the NT TK
210 you then add a second NT TK 210
interpret label with biotin and the
color is developed using also Irish
peroxidase labeled with with
streptavidin
it's good wide essay range if
a sensitive he's got linear dilution
it's very precise it's got long shelf
life so you can keep it on stock until
the samples arrive
tk1 is quite an easy protein to work
with it's that at room temperature while
you're working with it it could be kept
at 4 degrees for short times so it could
be shipped and it's a long-term storage
it can be kept frozen so you can do
respective retrospective studies or
prognostic studies
as I mentioned in him throaty
malignancies it's quite it's quite
similar results to the traditional tk1
enzyme activity assays so you can build
a traditional data
tumors in this example for breast cancer
is much more sensitive for tk1 than the
enzyme activity assays it can be
profitably combined with other tumor
biomarkers
are coming out on this application
examples so getting to the conclusion
tk1 is a biomarker cell proliferation is
a forward-looking biomarker Samuel s
reflected is activity patient subject
classification a career-making prognosis
and monitoring disease progression
TK one has different forms is solid in
humans of logical malignancies enzyme
activity IC underestimate TK one in
solid tumors and RSO TK 2 T invite
emissions all forms of spirit TK 1 so
you get good agreement with clinical
results based on TK 1 enzyme activity I
Cindy hematological malignancies greater
sensitivity of solid tumors in sorry
great sensitive or solid tumors and more
comparable results between types of
malignancy if a standard Eliza procedure
is applicable to in Bayesian models it's
an open system and it's CE marked
so thank you for listening ladies and
gentlemen I've been presenting the
acetic acid analyzer a novel biomarker
of cell proliferation and as we say we
measure what really matters it expands
and simplifies the study of certainly
proliferation and provides new
opportunities for cancer research and I
look forward to seeing your questions
and I'll answer them as best I can thank
you for your attention thank you March
and for that informative presentation I
would also like to thank levers for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 27th 2019 as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time goodbye